so texas is the state into which the
majority of these migrants are coming
greg abbott is the governor of texas he
has announced that he is building a
border wall in texas to protect his
state this strikes us as big news i'm
grateful to have governor abbott join us
now to explain what he's doing governor
thanks a lot for coming on so to tell us
you are building a border wall
we are and uh tucker this is
unprecedented uh both in speed and
in reason because uh never before has a
state of the united states of america
had to step up and build its own border
wall we have to do that because of all
the things that you were talking about
that joe biden has done
but also the speed with which we've been
able to do this i just signed a document
exactly six months ago directing the
texas facilities commission to begin
building a border wall and then months
after that i signed two budgets where
texas taxpayers are spending three
billion dollars that's with a b three
billion dollars for texas to do the
federal government's job to step up and
secure the border a large portion of
that money is going to build this border
wall i don't know if you're showing
images of it or not but the border wall
that we're building is built
by some of the people who built the
border wall for
the trump administration and it's the
exact same wallace 30 feet high is made
out of steel rods the steel rods are
about six inches by six inches
and this is an extraordinary barrier
that we're putting up by the football
field per day
we're putting up well over 100 yards
each and every day we're going to
continue to build this and i can explain
to you in part why we're able to move so
rapidly even faster than the trump
administration was able to move
first
part of the land that we're building on
is owned by the state of texas
second there are so many large
landowners on the border who are so fed
up with the administration they are
allowing texas to build the border wall
on their property we have
a 100 miles or so of land that's being
donated to the state of texas for us to
build the wall to better secure our
border it's amazing i mean for hundreds
of years people have kind of gone back
and forth between mexico and texas it's
never been a huge deal
i mean you know texas was never uptight
about immigration and then but the scale
of it got so crazy
it seems like people's attitudes are
changing
well people people's attitudes are
changing uh especially those who live on
the border right as you point out people
coming across the border it was kind of
commonplace however tucker the the
people who live on the border are
primarily hispanic
and the hispanics who live on the border
are fed up with these open border
policies candidly they're socialistic
policies
and that is exactly why you see all of
these counties on the border they voted
overwhelmingly
strongly in favor of president trump and
they are turning republican because they
are against the socialistic policies
that are being advocated by the
administration
open border policies are globalist
policies that are destroying the united
states of america and that's why we're
building the border wall that's why we
have the national guard on the border is
why we are arresting and jailing these
people who are coming across the border
it's an amazing development i appreciate
your coming on to explain it to us
tonight governor abbott of texas thanks
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else